Jay I've now seen you more than I see
most of my friends
I'm sorry and nice to see you again as
well
yeah uh yeah uh first of all a great
talk with you both this morning
um or this afternoon whatever the [__]
time it is no idea uh exactly again so
like you crack the lid on the bug I love
it Steve thank you so now we can
actually tell you the name of the show
yeah
wait oh yeah I just realized that um so
I heard you had to have been in a
Terminator movie to be in this show so
Jay how did you actually get casts oh
yeah I was in a Robocop so it's the next
best thing I guess yeah you know there's
a story Arnold has a story about that
I'll tell you in a minute well no he he
saw Paul bearhoven at uh I think it was
Musso's or something around that time
and he walked up because he wanted to
work with verhoven and Veron was like
thought he was coming over to get mad at
him because he he ripped off he's the
Terminator at least in his mind he's
cool so you thought you'd come tell me I
ripped off that's cool well listen
you've both done uh scenes with Arnold
um and I'm curious what is does it take
a few seconds when you're standing
across from him and you're doing that
first take when you're first walking
with working with him to sort of like
take a moment to like not be a kid to
realize wait do you know what I mean yes
and you're never not a kid I I never got
used to it you know it was a constant
thing to worry about I was like I
because I was like I've gotta ask and
I've got to be present and someone said
acting is reacting once and but
meanwhile like I'm sure there's a lot of
rushes or dailies of me just like
just in awe you know
um it's crazy it's still crazy it was
never not crazy
is that a Total Recall shirt it is yeah
oh it is and I just interviewed Arnold
and he got a real kick out of it so day
mate yeah I had a boy had a boy Steve
yeah no but but Jay's absolutely right
it never it never gets any any uh uh
it's always as incredible as was the
first time listen you guys were
obviously both fans do you have a
favorite Arnold movie certainly yeah uh
Last Action Hero I think
um yeah I go to a recall yeah oh by the
way both are great I think total
Terminator really but but for me I've
just It Last Action Hero has uh
spectacular but the thing about all his
films is there's always an entry point
for for the for kids right and you know
you you can see yourself as John Connor
you can see yourself as the kid in Last
Action Euro one of The Kindergartners in
kindergarten you know I mean uh Alyssa
Milano and Commando that would be my
number two command over here that was
great really number two is Commando I
would have to be yeah
he kills everybody and he's in I mean
he's in peace he's in he's a condition
[__] unit in that movie yeah
he takes he takes the Jeep all the way
down the hill
amazing Listen by the way there's no
wrong answer yeah I just like I mean
there's there's no wrong answer I mean
well there is if someone was like the
long goodbye you'd be like oh shut up
[__]
well that's someone who hasn't seen his
movies yeah yeah what do you think soon
to be fans of this series would be
surprised to learn about the actual
making of the show oh uh I I I would
assume
um because uh I don't know that it was
like a pretty pretty joyous lovely light
Airy uh uh working space it was like
summertime in Toronto everybody was kind
of for the most part in a good mood uh
it was lovely out we were
um a lot of a lot of good uh bell all
the bells and whistles when it came to
like craft service and stuff and uh yeah
and then we were doing something cool
lots of lots of fighting and car crashes
and and guns and stuff and explosions
and like yeah it was just it was a blast
I was like going into amusement park
every day uh schnitzel Fridays big big
thing
with Arnold and whenever he works it's
uh they they've just brought in a
cutting board a mountain of schnitzel
and lemon wedges uh you wouldn't know
that but that's what fueled us on
Fridays so yeah yeah by the way it's so
funny I've been lucky enough to do a
number of set visits and it's amazing uh
you can you can see the energy on set
when the craft service is another level
you can just everyone's just in a great
mood correct correct that's true there's
a difference it makes a big difference
100 so the the the season is eight
episodes for each of you which is your
favorite episode and why uh I think to
be honest this is gonna sound like a
compound but the earnest answers the the
the the first uh the opener and the
closer are both like like there are no
skippables here like there's no tracking
skip over they're all they're all strong
they're all a sides but like that first
one is as strong a pilot as I've ever
seen of any show and uh and our finale
is like uh oh man spectacular so I I
know personally I love those two
I'm in a I'm in agreement I think that's
that's a good answer the first is just
also the first is special to me because
you get to see borrow
um kind of in his element and also with
his most
honest uh feelings towards towards
Arnold's character and you get to and
you get to see that actually you know
obviously flip by the end of the episode
but the uh so I love the pilot and and
uh and the card game the card game was
really fun I didn't have a lot to do in
that scene but there was there's a
really great um
interaction with the CIA team during
that episode that's
you know a lot of Truth is spoken and
it's really funny enjoy that one I get
listen uh before I run out of time as a
huge fan of Last of Us I definitely have
to ask you when did you when you were
making it did you realize how special it
was going to be
um
I I could tell that
I mean we had some of the best Craftsmen
in every department so I mean it was
like John Peno our production Center you
literally just go on a set and realize
that
you felt because you having already been
immersed in the game
uh you you just just to be able to be
there and and uh and feel the textures
you know these these game designers are
spending hours now as I was building
these textures and now you have them and
just everything is tangible and um so I
had the sense that we were making it at
the highest level we possibly could in
every department whether or not the the
the audience is going to react the way
they did was was really uh there's no
way of telling but I mean it was
literally week to week by the millions
they were they were coming to the show
and that was just a tribute to
friends telling friends and that's uh
and most of them were non-gamers so
long I guess long answer long there's no
way of knowing but we were all you know
overwhelmed by by the how positive
people were uh I've been given the wrap
up signal I'll just say that I noticed
on collider the first few weeks it was
like a certain level but by the end it
had just been it was a whole another
Beast uh with people wanting to read
content and read articles and you know
just well I appreciate your work Steve I
always have man it's always great
talking to you and I love you all over
there at collider so appreciate it uh on
that note Jay uh good luck to whatever
team you're rooting for in the NHL yeah
I you know when my team is done I'm done
so uh they can all go [__] in the sea as
far as I'm concerned I mean the Flames
the Flames almost made the play I was
there at the end and yeah once they were
out I'm out yeah there you go oh boy I'm
a flames
that no good luck with the rest of the
speed dating thank you guys so much
thank you pal have a good one